اليوم بعد الدواب اليوم بظل هذه الحرب ليس
يوجد لديهم طعام يعني ليس يوجد لديه
الشعير يبذلون بدل الشعير بالقمح والقمح
يسبب المقفل اكثر من فوق ال 50 دابه حتى
هذه
اللحظه صقر الجمال سكان منطقه البرازيل
بيتنا انهدم نزحنا لهذا المكان اللي هي
مدارس الواء في ظل الحرب هذه وظل قطع
السولر وقطع السيارات في قطاع غزه ادى الى
المواطنين ان ان ركبوا الى هذه الكارت
ويكون هناك لديهم شغل لديهم عمل كبير لهذه
الكارات يعني نتحدث قبل الحرب كانت
اسعارها منخفضه جدا اليوم ارتفعت الاسعار
بطاق فيظل هذه الحرب الي تش عن قطاع غزه
وظل عدم دخول السر قطاع غزه اليوم بعد
الدواب اليوم بظل هذه الحرب ليس يوجد
لديهم طعام يعني ليس يوجد لديهم الشعير
يبذلون بدل الشعير بالقمح والقمح سبب من
المقفل اكثر من فوق ال 50 دابه حتى هذه
اللحظه ومن اول ساعه لهذا المكان بدات ان
تاتي الد من المناطق الشرقيه كما اعتاد
البدو هم اصحاب هذه المواشي فذهبوا لهذا
المكان فيوم يوم على يوم كانت هناك اقدام
الدواب الى اكبر كميات في هذا المكان وتم
البيع كل يوم يتم كميات كبيره من بيع
الدواب في هذا المكان كالحمير كالحصن
كيكون هناك اصحاب لهذا الشيء هم الاصحاب
تحدث عنهم الدلالين لهذا الشيء يقف الدلال
على القاره وثم يدلل على هذا على هذا
الحمار او الحصان بالنسبه للمواصلات في
مدينه رفع بال تحديدا يعني ينخل الراكب من
منطقه البلد ال منطقه الجنينه بسعر ث شيكل
للقاره اليوم يعني زي ما قلت لكول ما في
سول وفي سيارات اليوم البديل الوحيد هو في
قطاع غزه هو هو الركب على الكارت وعلى
الحمير وعلى الحصن هذا هو الموجود في قطاع
غزه وفي علينا الحمد لله في ب عليه بشتغل
يعني بعمل كل يوم 200 250 شكل في عليه عمل
يعني فرص العمل اليوم متوفر لهن كثيره جدا
هذا هو سبب غلاهم في قطاع
غزه